[Música]
hoy termina en el estado de Luisiana en
el sur de Estados Unidos la visita del
presidente de Francia Emanuel Mako el
mandatario reiteró Los lazos históricos
que unen esta región de Estados Unidos
con París y reafirmó su interés en
preservar el idioma francés y la cultura
gala en esa zona conectamos en unos
minutos con nuestra oleada especial a la
ciudad de Nueva Orleans
la Unión Europea fija un tope al precio
del petróleo ruso los integrantes del
bloque comunitario acordaron un límite
de 60 dólares por barril como parte de
las represalias contra Moscú acordadas
junto al g7 por la guerra contra Ucrania
ampliamos desde Bruselas
y Bolivia fijó la fecha del censo de
población y vivienda para marzo del 2024
el anuncio llega después de las
protestas ciudadanas en el departamento
de Santa Cruz que dejaron cuatro muertos
y cientos de heridos en reclamo a un
censo que debería ser realizado en el
2023 para actualizar su representación
legislativa y también para aumentar la
cantidad de fondos estatales que recibe
ese departamento considerado el motor
económico de Bolivia
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en Estados
Unidos el presidente de Francia Emanuel
majó finalizó su visita o ya está
ultimando sus últimas visitas en Estados
Unidos en la ciudad de Nueva Orleans en
el estado de Luisiana que en el pasado
perteneció justamente a Francia y que
fue vendido al gobierno de Estados
Unidos y en donde quedan todavía unos
pequeños remanentes de ciudadanos cuya
lengua materna es precisamente el
francés justamente uno de los motivos de
su visita fue reforzar y Buscar
mecanismos para garantizar la
supervivencia del idioma en esa zona de
la Unión Americana vamos a conectar
hasta la ciudad de Nueva Orleans allá se
encuentra mamen sala nuestra enviada
especial a esta zona de Estados Unidos
mamen muy buenas noches y bueno que es
lo último que se sabe de Esta visita del
mandatario francés que todavía no
termina
muy buenas noches Santiago todavía no la
verdad es que el presidente francés aquí
ha sido muy querido ha llegado ha estado
paseando por las calles de New Orleans
que estáis yendo detrás de mí se ha dado
un baño de masas porque aquí como decías
hay muchos expatriados franceses que
querían salir a saludar al presidente
Manuel macron lo hemos visto también
bailar delante de las cámaras hemos oído
ese grito de viva Francia y ha estado
paseando con la alcaldesa de esta ciudad
y con el vicegobernador y han llegado
hasta aquí a este edificio que estáis
viendo detrás de mí que es la colección
histórica de New Orleans aquí ha tenido
un encuentro con el gobernador de
Luisiana y junto y él y la ministra
francesa para Europa y asuntos
exteriores Katherine colon han firmado
un memorando en presencia del presidente
francés por el cual van a crear un
puesto dentro del grupo de trabajo para
la lucha contra el cambio climático
crearán un puesto para un experto
francés en transición
la verdad es que tiene todo sentido del
mundo que Luisiana sea este telón de
fondo para hablar sobre cambio climático
y sobre eso y sobre este tipo de
energías renovables porque es uno de los
estados más castigados por el cambio
climático aquí el nivel del agua va
subiendo cada vez más y amenaza la costa
además también en esas conversaciones
que han tenido se ha hablado también del
gas natural licuado no olvidemos que en
un momento en el que
debido
a la invasión por parte de Rusia en
Ucrania muchas naciones europeas están
buscando diferentes Fuentes y esta
podría ser una de ellas una amplia
agenda mamen que todavía resta algunos
puntos por finalizar de lo que resta de
este día apretado allí en Luisiana que
más le falta por hacer al presidente
allí
tremendamente apretado Santiago ahora
mismo está a punto de ofrecer un
discurso en el Museo de Arte de New
Orleans se espera que empiecen pocos
minutos y para reafirmar la cultura
francesa y su compromiso el compromiso
de Francia con promocionar aquí la
cultura francesa además también está
previsto que apruebe un fondo para
invertir en la enseñanza en escuelas
estadounidenses para que se enseñe el
francés en las escuelas estadounidenses
para que os hagáis una idea aquí en este
estado hay más de 32 programas de
inmersión del lenguaje francés y más de
150 maestros procedentes de Francia como
decías va a ser una agenda de lo más
apretada luego se espera que el
presidente francés pasee por el centro
de esta ciudad y disfrute de la mayor
atracción turística que hay aquí en New
Orleans que es no sé si lo podéis
Escuchar Precisamente en la música en
directo y sobre todo el jazz
mamen Muchas gracias por este reporte
desde Nueva Orleans Gracias por esos
detalles a lo largo de la jornada y a
disfrutar un poquito aunque sea del jazz
ahora que ya está finalizando el día
Muchas gracias por este reporte vamos a
cambiar de tema Hablamos ahora de la
Unión Europea que acordó fijar un tope
al precio del petróleo ruso los
integrantes del bloque comunitario
acordaron un límite de 60 dólares por
barril como parte de las en represalias
contra Moscú que fueron acordadas junto
al g7 debido a la invasión rusa al
territorio de Ucrania Rusia ya había
reaccionado ante la esta posibilidad y
aseguró que prohibiría la venta de
petróleo a los países que apliquen este
tope de precio a la energía previamente
conversamos con Esther Herrera nuestra
corresponsal de France 24 en la ciudad
de Bruselas sede de la Unión Europea y
nos dio más detalles
han sido varios días de negociaciones a
contrarreloj pero finalmente los países
europeos han acordado poner un tope
máximo al precio del petróleo ruso tal y
como se había acordado hace unos meses
en el seno del g7 en concreto se pone un
techo máximo de 60 dólares por barril
aún así hay que tener en cuenta esta
nueva acuerdo no afecta en absoluto a
los países de la Unión Europea porque
hay que tener en cuenta que a partir de
este lunes 5 de diciembre ningún país
europeo podrá importar ni petróleo ni
sus derivados provenientes de Rusia sica
la práctica esto sobre todo lo que
afecta es a las navieras europeas que no
podrán transportar de ninguna manera
petróleo a ningún lugar del mundo que se
haya pagado por encima de estos 60
dólares el objetivo es asfixiar aún más
a la economía rusa porque dependen en
gran medida de la exportación de
petróleo para que así otros países del
mundo se vean obligados también a pagar
estos 60 dólares y reducir así los
ingresos de Rusia aún así esto
evidentemente también tiene un impacto
en las navieras europeas que tienen una
importante cuota de Mercado sobre todo
las griegas y chipriotas aún así Fuentes
diplomáticas aseguran que este es un
buen acuerdo y que creen que varios
países del mundo se van a poder sumar
esta nueva medida porque el precio del
barril va a seguir subiendo se espera
que este nuevo acuerdo pueda entrar en
vigor los próximos días muy
probablemente antes de que acabe el fin
de semana
Hablamos ahora de las autoridades
ucranianas que están investigando las
actividades en la Guerra de Ucrania de
la iglesia ortodoxa rusa institución muy
cercana al gobierno del presidente de
Rusia Vladimir Putin una cercanía que
los patriarcas religiosos no han negado
gif rompió formalmente sus lazos con la
iglesia ortodoxa rusa desde el pasado
mes de mayo y creó su propia división de
esta iglesia a nivel local los
cristianos ortodoxos constituyen la
mayoría de los 43 millones de ciudadanos
que viven en Ucrania
medidas drásticas contra las
organizaciones religiosas vinculadas a
Rusia un anuncio hecho por el presidente
boludimir zenenski en su discurso
nocturno
el Consejo de Seguridad nacional y
defensa ha dado instrucciones al
gobierno para que proponga al parlamento
un proyecto de ley sobre la prohibición
de las actividades en Ucrania de las
organizaciones religiosas afiliadas a
los centros de influencia de la
federación rusa
de la iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana apoyada
por Rusia conocida como el patriarcado
de Moscú tenía derecho a operar en uno
de los lugares más sagrados de Ucrania
el complejo de Peters
un lugar que fue asaltado la semana
pasada por las fuerzas ucranianas en un
intento de contrarrestar lo que se
considera actividades subversivas de los
servicios especiales rusos el líder de
la iglesia ortodoxa el patriarca quiril
ha expresado su apoyo a Putin y a la
guerra
la primera línea de defensa en el mundo
ruso el mundo ruso no es solo Rusia sino
que está en todos los lugares en los que
vive la gente que ha sido educada en las
tradiciones de la ortodoxia quien las
tradiciones de la moral rusa un hecho
que ha provocado divisiones en mayo una
parte de la iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana
rompió sus lados con Rusia debido a la
invasión pasamos ahora a América Latina
Vamos hasta Bolivia el gobierno fijó la
ley que establece la fecha para realizar
el censo de población y vivienda en ese
país que será realizado entonces en
marzo del 2024 a pesar de las protestas
ciudadanas que reclamaban su realización
en el año 2023 sin embargo la medida
sigue causando polémica particularmente
en el departamento de Santa Cruz que es
el motor económico del país y también
bastión opositor donde se registraron
protestas y huelgas durante más de un
mes que dejaron Al menos cuatro personas
fallecidas y cientos de heridos Santa
Cruz pide actualizar su representación
legislativa y también la cantidad de
fondos estatales que recibe del gobierno
central boliviano por eso necesitaba
realizar este censo en el 2023 los
opositores cruceños argumentan que el
gobierno central buscaba retrasar la
fecha del censo para evitar darle más
recursos económicos
la ley que se aprobó en las cámaras de
diputados y senadores no es una ley de
la derecha es una ley propuesta por
nuestros diputados del más ipcp que no
vulnera competencias de nivel central
del estado con algunos asambleístas del
más y PSP diputados y senadores
hemos tenido una mirada distinta sobre
la naturaleza de un conflicto y la forma
de resolverlo Pero eso no significa que
seamos enemigos Ni que tengamos
Horizontes políticos distintos y Brasil
sigue haciendo frente a intensas lluvias
que han afectado varios estados del país
que han dejado casas y vías sumergidas
unas 800 personas tuvieron que abandonar
sus hogares en el estado de Santa
Catarina allí las autoridades en el sur
del país declararon el estado de
emergencia por estas Fuertes lluvias que
ustedes ven en las imágenes en esa
región al menos dos personas han perdido
la vida también un bombero que estaba
participando en una operación de rescate
fue arrastrado por la fuerzas de la
corriente en el vecino Estado de Paraná
los equipos de rescate continúan
trabajando también en la búsqueda de
decenas de desaparecidos que dejó un
deslizamiento de tierra que afectó una
carretera federal
y en otros temas la Organización Mundial
la salud manifestó su satisfacción tras
asegurar que china ahora comienza a
relajar sus restricciones contra el Coby
19 a raíz de las protestas en todo el
país por la respuesta pandémica y esa
línea dura que ha dado Beijing pero
aunque la OMS resaltó la situación en el
país asiático alertó que la relajación
de las medidas en el mundo podría llevar
a apariciones de nuevas variantes mucho
más agresivas escuchemos al director de
emergencias de esta organización Michael
Ryan
nos complace saber que las autoridades
chinas están Ajustando sus estrategias
actuales y realmente tratando de
calibrar ahora las medidas de control
que necesitan para este virus en sus
vidas en los medios de subsistencia y
los Derechos Humanos de las personas en
las comunidades que han como todo el
mundo sufrido
Todos hemos tenido que lidiar con
restricciones de movimiento Todos hemos
tenido que lidiar con cambios en
nuestras vidas
y Miren esta historia en Estados Unidos
El rapero kanye West está siendo
señalado tras unos comentarios neonazis
y antisemitas que ha hecho que le
bloqueen su cuenta de Twitter por
segunda vez debido a la gran influencia
como uno de los músicos más escuchados
en el mundo Alba Santana nos cuenta más
en su informe
una vez más en la polémica rica Es sobre
la figura del rapero y diseñador kanye
West en esta ocasión a por estos
comentarios de corte neonazi
algo que además de violentar a la
comunidad judía y ganarle un aluvión de
críticas habitado al conocido como y de
Twitter Solo dos meses después de que le
devolvieran la cuenta ya que ni siquiera
el propietario y multimillonario y lo
más firme defensor de lo que denomina
libertad de expresión ha podido ignorar
Esto está bien
esto no está bien Lo hice lo mejor que
pude a pesar de eso volvió a violar
nuestra Norma contra la incitación de
violencia la cuenta será suspendida Esta
no es la primera vez que el famoso
artista se ve envuelto en uno de estos
escándalos tanto por sus comentarios
antisemitas en el pasado motivo por el
que le habían bloqueado la cuenta como
para arremeter contra otras celebridades
e incluso Víctimas de violencia fue el
caso de George Floyd el hombre
afroamericano que murió luego que un
policía sostuviera sus rodillas sobre su
cuello durante casi nueve minutos y
sobre el que ya sugirió que podría haber
muerto por el uso del fentanilo
declaraciones que le han puesto en el
centro de las críticas y le han hecho
perder contratos multimillonarios como
el de Adidas o balenciaga
ya no tengo manager porque no puedo ser
manejado algo que algunos han abordado
con humor desde las redes
[Música]
en la cabeza de kanye West él es así soy
un hombre blanco de 35 años de edad pero
que genera mucha preocupación por los
valores que promociona el músico uno de
los más escuchados del mundo
en un día como hoy pero hace 30 años Fue
enviado el primer mensaje corto de texto
de la historia el cual tenía como
contenido precisamente un saludo de
navidad sin embargo su uso ha disminuido
a partir de la creación de las
aplicaciones de mensajes instantáneos
pese a esto el SMS se rehúsa a
desaparecer y las compañías de servicio
telefónico le encuentran cada vez más
formas de aplicación Como por ejemplo
fines publicitarios
esto en las noticias siga con nosotros
[Música]